and now it's time for that cartoon show
with cartoons all right Ben
you have nowhere to hide now tell us
what the hell's been going on since we
crashed on this island what if I told
you jack that all the answers to all the
questions about this island was simply
behind this door what are you talking
about I'm saying that everything the
polar bear the smoke monster the
time-traveling all the answers are
behind this single solitary door he's
lying let's kill the bastard no what if
he's right
are you crazy doc I know he's betrayed
us before but somehow I feel like this
time he's telling us the truth all right
Ben opened the door
che che aprons
I got nothing what uh yeah I got nothing
what do you mean you got nothing you
seek eight years ago I was looking for a
show to follow on the success of alias I
new ideas something to keep everybody's
attention so I got high and came up with
a show about an island where all sorts
of weird shit happens I want to call it
the Revenge of Gilligan's Island but the
executives thought Lost wasn't much
catchier title so I came up with this
ridiculous story that kept everybody's
attention because they had no idea what
was going on because I had no idea what
was going on and I had no idea what it
was all gonna add up to you mean the
pirate ship the healings the constant
appearances of dead people all came out
of my ass huh all or bear on an island
do you really think I could explain that
well why are you telling us now I mean
won't the be always be angry at you
don't need them they've already made me
stinking rich you see as long as I could
stretch out my bullshit for a number of
seasons everyone would keep watching and
thus make me lots and lots of money you
are feeling right so now if you'll
excuse me I have to film Star Trek
negative - I'll leave you all with this
image of me swimming in your money while
I make out with two beautiful women
whose names I can afford not to remember
enjoy
you